hi guys my name's Terry chambers and I'm
Cody Melchior and this is Tamra Jessa
and Cody also just saw two as well in
space we just saw guardians of the
galaxy - and before that I still have
some more thoughts about thoughts baby -
if he's just a baby how is he driving
cars and eating should I okay we'll save
that for next time
guardians of the galaxy do the tone and
the narrative really wove through like
yondu's arrow can you do that whistle no
I can't whistle
I can only whistle where it sounds like
an Arctic cave quiet simple I like it
this s the opposite of me I was going
into this very excited because guardians
of the galaxy one is by far one of my
favorite Marvel movies it took me the
first half of the movie to get really
into it I would then do it I was
enjoying it the second half was just so
killer and so what I wanted for the film
that wasn't disappointed by the first
half but I'm glad that that the second
half was the way it was I was in it to
win it from minute one I was ready to go
I can see where you're coming from and I
can agree with it if I weren't already
just like the moment the movie started I
was like let's do it lock and load
strap it in I tightened my belt several
notches and I was going for it it was
such a blast and pursue the opening
sequence
it's just Groot is running around it so
she's just dancin rudra the cutest
character ya up to the point where
somebody like said that in the movie
Hader faces like he's too adorable to
kill and they take him to the tailor to
get him an outfit
no and then opening scene really sets a
good tone because not only does it set
up like okay these are the stakes like
life or death except the the
relationship dynamic really quick
between everybody to the point where is
like you could have almost not seen the
first one and really kind of just still
pretty jumped into it pretty quick who's
really really I'm impressed it was all
done I loved it I loved it it's my new
boyfriend we're getting married in the
spring I had such a blast that I loved
it
so much it just took a while for them to
set up what the actual movie was leading
up to there was a lot of things
happening which not to take too much it
wasn't like a like a mazing spider-man
to where they're like trying to fit
everything in it was really good but the
main chunk of the movie the main chunk
of the plot didn't really reveal itself
until a good portion of the way in short
it didn't like piss me off and it was
like noticeable I know I don't know if
we agree on this I did not enjoy the
gold people plot I think they were
boring I didn't love them they could
have easily not been in the film and it
would have been just fun and I know they
needed that extra bit of conflict and I
know that they were setting things up
and and you see what they were setting
up in like one of the end role credit
scenes but that didn't really like they
were a part of the whole movies was
weird that I was just in the n roll'
credit for me right I agreed that they
are they were not necessarily fantastic
in terms of like being a part of the
plot but I don't think they were
supposed to be they were kind of a they
were a match okay my reaction is more
that I just I the High Priestess is
aesthetic like so it's every chair in
the next ten years does it have a hat
attached to it I'm gone like that you
can just step out of it is just like
stays on the chair Oh mad my dream in
life is to walk places where someone's
rolling a carpet up in front of me as I
was like yeah these are kind of
inconsequential but it's worth it high
braces character fiancee's fine but high
priestess
I mean Jodi's use way more high
predisposition when she steps out of the
throat and her chrome stays on it I
literally went I mean they looked
awesome I think it's so cool to make it
that they use in these films the High
Priestess Gamora and nebula I think that
is awesome I really wanna do right yeah
I think what helps some of the slow
parts that Tamra's talking about is
because there's so many different things
going on there's so many different
storylines happening that you get to
have this moment with Peter and his
father
you get like it's a long drawn-out kind
of really like you know family moment
it's supposed to be like a heart
touching moment didn't care is a
character-driven part but in the middle
of that you get a great scene you get a
really great action scene with yondu and
so it's like you don't lose the tension
and the character and relationship stuff
it's building over there it's like you
get that and you can put it aside a
little bit and have like a fun little
like yondu side John for me didn't
become the movie it was trying to become
until it took a while and I know it
needs that builds but I just took a
second I think the only reason why I and
saying that even at all about it being a
little like trying to find its place is
because I'm trying to like develop my
movie critical thinking skills except
these aren't reviews they're just
reactions but I I'm just like trying
never got to a film before and like
tried to pick out anything that was
wrong with it I just enjoy the out
of all of them and so now I'm trying to
like actively find something that I
think could have been improved upon and
it was hard in this one this was a fun
movie the comedy especially I think in
the action was so flippin fun and
there's like Comi throughout it's all
great but in the high intensity moment
so they still take a moment you have
like a hilarious line yeah it was so
massively done in terms of the tone that
you could have the action going and it
would dip into a funny moment and come
back right into the action and then you
could quickly turn it into like a really
sad moment I mean there were some jokes
that fell flat and it's like that's
gonna happen they're growing a ton of
jokes out the script is so able to like
jump in it out comedy and action also
like these really emotional themes that
they totally earned I cried oh yeah
hewed comes to me when I was younger
been like I want at some point in your
life you're going to cry at the sight of
different spaceship showing up at a play
haha you want to believe that here cuz I
read a little we do have to talk about
the greatest moment in the entire movie
which is when Emma Watson gets hit in
the face book so you really fell flat
the first time but this time man there's
literally
I give too much away there's literally a
seed where this like dramatic moment has
happened I said one of the characters
just gets mad the pony is laughing so
loud that it made other people in the
theater laugh like it was a funny moment
whatever we like all he's enjoying it so
again shows a perfect balance of
screenwriting in like seven in the
tenterhooks that they had everything on
that they could really play with the
delicacy of those moment cuz it was so
funny because it was a really earned
like dramatic action moment where I was
because it is you whatsoever Jeff
Bridges within that camera loves that
[Laughter]
except for this is my favorite that was
amazing Kurt Russell was awesome in this
the casting between them was amazing
that was perfect
crazy similar there is one character
that is discussed multiple times
throughout the movie that does not show
up at all or in the final credits scenes
and I was a little disappointed about
that just because like oh he's a pretty
big deal and it would have been nice to
have some sort of time again with him in
some capacity but I am super excited for
the person that they teased try not to
be spoilers they tease one specific
character for the next one I kind of had
the opposite thing with Tamara where I
tend to cuz I went I went to film school
I have a tendency to be too critical
especially screenwriting and so
sometimes with the fun action adventure
movies I try to kind of turn off as much
as I can but I think it did I think it
did a generally good job that might be
because I've lowered my expectations for
superhero movies a lot but I think the
guardians have been two of the best
those in Blankman
you don't want to marry a white man five
I was saying this in the car I think
whereas the first one was this comedy
fun action adventure this was this
comedy fun action adventure that also
had awesome character development and
really got me soaked for the third one
in a way that I just I remember feeling
this and
not for any other superior franchise but
this way for the first two spider-men
movies spider-man spider-man 2 the spot
on the fighter miss excuse me often
you'll see smaller than somebody spotted
been all over the place I saw the first
spider-man movie and I just was blown
away I was like my first superhero film
and I felt the same way after the second
and then the third one really let me
down
I usually lose with the energy of Tobey
Maguire things that I had a problem with
what problems they were just like
observations I guess and looked at solid
observations I would
I will cosign and back up those
observations thank you I give it a I
give it a 9 Kurt Russell's out of 10
Jeff Bridges I give it 7 brain planets I
give it a hundred and to ghost in the
shell is that like Gulf where you want
let's go this is shuffle yes you always
want let's go to the show everything so
much better to see this and talk about
it with somebody else to thank you for
being back always happy to be here um
and we will see you and I missed you
about saying I'm in front of it we will
see you next week
thank you for watching fly safe be a
buff Baby Bop
[Music]